what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be reacting to the new Spider-Man
trailer my producer blessing always
causing a ruckus here at jpt um has said
I need to pay attention to some things
in this trailer I don't know what so I'm
I'm excited to see
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever wow
whatever so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian I am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what
did your parents not let you get bees I
mean I my mom was okay with the bee the
C she would get mad at but she said you
could get one C I was like okay maybe
you guys had higher expectations than
mine did we just weren't really big
school people did I miss something what
did I missed
he's lying to you and I think you know
it
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing was his
idea what's it I gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter miles
[Music]
I'll take it from here
wait where'd the baby come from did
Spider-Man actually ever have kids I
don't remember I haven't seen Spider-Man
in Forever being Spider-Man is a
sacrifice
[Music]
do you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
[Music]
send me home I can't do that I can do
both oh there's another Spider-Man
there's two oh he's like the Spider-Man
in training okay man always always what
about Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben
most of us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend am I missing something
it looks like a lit movie you go too far
you won't notice it I read what this
says here at the back I literally can't
read it protect trans kids are they
trans I don't know but what what is it
right there and this is a kids movie
yeah this is okay okay this is why
blessing I'm so against sex ed I'm so
anti-sex Ed they're trying to brainwash
the children into God knows what I don't
know why but it's like why does a kid
need to know what a trans person is
actually no look it's actually the flag
it's a flag with the protect trans kids
on it well there shouldn't be trans kids
if you're an 18 not Jesus
[Music]
I feel you I can't lose any more friends
either if you know you know
[Music]
yeah I would not have picked up on the
flag though I don't know how everyone
noticed that I actually think it's kind
of a fire commercial I'm not gonna lie
like I mean I'm not for the trans part
you know let's keep the kids away from
that person
let me guess he died
laughs
I mean I'm not even gonna lie this movie
looks fire here's the hard part when you
don't want to support like certain
content because it's like you don't
really agree with what they stand for
but the movie looks fire I'm not a big
movie person so this doesn't really
apply to me but it does look like a good
movie um anyways guys let me know if you
picked up on it or not you know whatever
uh subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time